es ist etwas schlimmes passiert ihr seht
schon wieder die kisten sind hinten
wieder falsch herum angeordnet
halt deine schnauze pikachu braucht es
geht hier wirklich um dieses thema back
to topic
wir haben vor einiger zeit eine mail
bekommen die für mich einiges verändert
hat ihr wisst ich gehe sehr vorsichtig
wir machen halt doch eine 5
diese mail hat mich schon sehr getroffen
ich muss mich einfach hinsetzen dafür
europa
wir sehen ja super kurz manchmal ist es
im leben einfach so dass man auf den
boden der tatsachen zurückgeholt wird
und damit egal was willst du dann bist
du überhaupt in mein zimmer es geht hier
um eine ernste sache ja gut ok stehe ich
wieder hier jetzt mal so wirklich auf
das thema zu kommen ich war im juni
irgendwann in london habt auch von
pokémon go video hochgeladen
pokémon sich in not und brauche ich dann
halt mal meine mails abgerufen und habe
dann eine mail bekommen mit dem betreff
kein betreff hat mir dabei natürlich
erstmal nicht viel gedacht dann habe ich
mir diese mail durchgelesen in der mail
stand hallo luca ich bin ein fan von dir
hier ist deine nummer da dachte ich mir
mit dicker hier hermann baumer vom
numbers also ergänzt es hat dann auf
jeden fall die nachricht weiter gelesen
er schrieb dann weiterhin wenn du mir
nicht noch whatsapp schreibst dann gebe
ich sie weiter hier schreibt nicht an
was bist du denn für ein armes würstchen
freunde ich bin wirklich sauer
luca ist sauer spend diesen hashtag
unter alle möglichen bilder bei
instagram bei youtube unter alle videos
dieses moment muss angefangen werden
fortgesetzt werden ich bin sauer
dann hat er mir halt seine nummer dann
geschrieben die man hier eingebettet das
ist natürlich also ich habe das
natürlich zensiert damit jetzt er nicht
ganz viele nachrichten von euch bekommen
natürlich ist er verständlich und jetzt
kommen wir zum wirklich interessanten
teilen und zwar wollte er beweisen dass
er wirklich meine nummer hat und
schreibe mir dann und das ist eine
nummer und das ist nicht wahr hält hofer
also schreibt mir das wissen für ein
mensch also ich glaube sein hobby ist es
einfach irgendwelchen leuten zu
schreiben er hält sich oder nummer und
schreibt dann die hacken kann
die sau raus ich schreibe also an dich
sehr verehrter typ denn wenn diese
melden wie heißt er überhaupt teddy free
wie google mal gucken ob wir dazu was
finden ein paar sekunden später also
wenn ich jetzt happy free bei google
eingeben kommt wow
wer hätte es gedacht aber ich meine wenn
ich mal auf seinen namen draufklicken
kommt mein gott da ist er wirklich seine
mail teddy freescale thomas sensi
mail.com also dieser typ heißt thomas
thomas die lokomotive oder werden aber
freunde vielleicht finden wir etwas zu
thomas teddy free im internet also wenn
ich thomas teddy free bei google
eingeben und dann auf bilderkrieg
gekommen es kommen wieder teddybären
umwelt
das erste bild was mir angezeigt wird
wenn man thomas teddy free 1 gib ist ein
thomas b
bremsten wie google mal wer das sein
könnte wenn man thomas bremsten bei
google eingibt ist das erste mal ein
bild von schafen
ich suche doch einfach nur den typen
denn wir diese mail geschrieben hat also
bisher haben wir die zwei theorien das
medi mail einerseits von thomas bremste
aus bradford aus england geschickt
worden hätte können tun oder heil thomas
die lokomotive ich tippe eindeutig auf
die lokomotive die zu beginn schon
gesagt dass ich mich mit sowas
auseinandersetzen müssen ein hashtag
luca ist sauer
spend es überall hinten jeder muss es
wissen freunde so kommen wir auf keinen
fall
hey so kommen wir nicht zu einem
entschluss nicht sein
ich gebe auch räume ich habe alles
probiert herauszufinden moment der hat
mir doch sogar seine nummer da
geschrieben
ich will euch seid ihr wirklich nicht
zeigen aber er hat mir in der welt
geschrieben seine nummer fängt mit plus
4 3 an also von was +43 die vorwahl also
laut ihm mit ipv4 verläuft sollte ich
erst mal die kamera um stellen also ich
habe hier eine karte gefunden werde ich
euch jetzt mal hier ein und da steht das
plus hier die formal ist für diese
folgenden länder hier wenn man sich dann
ein wenig weiterhin informiert habe ich
dann herausgefunden dass +43 die vorwahl
von österreich ich habe also die mail
von thomas teddy free aus österreich
bekommen
vielleicht finden wir ihn damit nach
mehreren stunden der internet recherche
fand luca ist nun endlich heraus ihr
ahnt es nicht ich kann es nicht fassen
ich habe gerade thomas de vries
österreich gegoogelt und was kann bei
den bilder vorschlägen raus pikachu ich
wusste es die ganze zeit warum schickst
du mir mails mit meiner angeblichen
handy geboren bringst dich voll auf die
pfeile das was ihr vom video haben das
rätsel löst meine damen und herren email
die xbox live schon wieder ich habe
diese mail einfach bekommen und hätte
eigentlich direkt gelöscht weil es
einfach erlogen ist oder wollt nicht
leute aufmerksamkeit aber ich habe mir
gedacht okay vielleicht hätte ich doch
über ein cooles video machen also wenn
es euch gefallen lassen auf jeden fall
mal wie schon mehrmals in diesem video
gesagt kommentiert herr staeck luca ist
sauer über alle möglichen videos unter
einem möglichen instagram bildern wir
müssen den leuten das einfach zeigen
dass ich sauber bin dir vorne seht ihr
uns meile eingeblendet da könnt ihr mich
mein kanal abonnieren und hier findet
die gegend ein random video verlinkt was
euch auf jeden fall mal geben sollte
kommentiert luca ist sauer letzte
familie thismoment ich habe mir mühe
geben im schnitt ich hoffe ihr extremes